my best to stay behind the camera and
not not appear in front of the camera as
we headed out to the firebase and the
Special Forces chopper and none of us
could imagine that we ourselves would
become part of the story before the trip
was over but the way events unfolded
everything changed in this trips
Afghanistan we did become part of the
story was because we were caught up in
the same mass casualty event as a lot of
the soldiers we were filming other than
the guys inside the vehicle we were
closest to the truck just 35 feet away
when it blew up
when it blew up I do remember in an
instant just seeing the back end of the
truck he pup into the air the sound was
so loud it was the only way I can
describe it as it was almost silent
there was a flash of light the flash of
light essentially seemed to consume my
cameraman Ryan Ryan just disappeared and
at that time I just figured he was dead
your reaction is holy I can't believe
that just happened to me I have a little
baby at home I have a wife what am I
doing here I'm here by choice I was
shocked I was surprised that I was
intact I was certain that I'd lost a
foot or a hand or an arm or something
when I first saw Ryan he was covered in
a blanket he looked pretty bad he was
going into shock
but I knew he was alive and I said to
him I said I thought you were dead man
and he looked at me and he said I
thought you were dead too
Ryan was injured worse than I was a lot
worse than I was I thought and he had
deep second-degree burns up and down his
arms and it on his face
we both had shrapnel through our faces
and up and down our arms and I too had
second-degree burns up and down my face
but not as deep as his in the dutch
field hospital
I reached over to Ryan and I held his
hand and he reached back and held my
hand and he said to me Steve it's not
your fault I don't blame you for what
happened we both made the decision to
come here
and uh you know I pretty much broke down
in tears a little bit because um that
weighed heavily on my mind making films
is always personal but this film had
become intensely personal
my cameraman was in a burn center we
both were at risk of losing our sight we
witness guys die in combat essentially
we'd witnessed a lot of other guys
suffer pretty significant wounds and we
weren't just gonna let the story go it
was too intensely personal by that time
hopefully we're just holding up a mirror
to a reality to what's going on out
there
people can take away from it just deeper
insight into the complexity of the war
being waged in Afghanistan and the
incredible difficulties and sacrifices
being made by those who are who are
waging that war the one thing that
strikes you when you get out there is
just how kind of resourceful these guys
are how autonomous and how alone I mean
how on their own they are
yeah we have the most powerful military
the world's ever created but these guys
are pretty much out there on their own
with what they have you know on the base
and at their disposal I don't want to
gather too much attention to well what I
went through and what the National
Geographic film crew went through
because the focus should be on on the
Special Forces soldiers who were out
there in the field and who are still out
there in the field and enduring all of
the hardships and dangers and losing
friends and taking risks every day we
went out for just a short brief window
of time and came back home these guys go
out and and see friends get killed and
wounded and then go out again the next
day and the next day and the next day